let's say that i have a 100 meter long
wire so that is my wire right over there
and it is 100 meters
and i'm going to make a cut someplace on
this wire
and so let's say i make the cut right
over there with the left section of y
i'm going to obviously cut it into with
the left section i am going to construct
an equilateral triangle i am going to
construct an equilateral triangle and
with the right section i am going to
construct a square i am going to
construct a square and my question for
you and for me is where do we make this
cut in order to minimize the combined
areas of this triangle and this square
well let's figure out let's define a
variable that we're trying to minimize
or that we're trying to
optimize with respect to
so let's say that the variable x is the
number of meters that we decide to cut
from the left so if we did that then
this
this length for the triangle would be x
meters and the length for the square
would be
well if we use x up for the left hand
side we're going to have 100
minus x for the right hand side
and so what would the dimensions of the
triangle and the square be
well the triangle sides are going to be
x over 3
x over 3
and x over 3 is an equilateral triangle
and the square is going to be 100
100 minus x over 4
by 100
minus x over 4.
now it's easy to figure out an
expression for the area of the square in
terms of x but let's think about what
the area of an equilateral triangle
might be as a function of the length of
its sides
so let me do a little bit of an aside
right over here so let's say we have an
equilateral triangle we have an
equilateral triangle
just like that and its sides are length
s
s
and s
now we know that the area we know that
the area of a triangle is one half times
the base
times the base times
the height so in this case the height we
could consider to be an altitude if we
were to drop an altitude just like this
this length right over here
this is the height and this would be
perpendicular just like that so
our area our area
is going to be equal to one-half times
our base is s
one-half times s times whatever our
height is times our height
now how can we express h as a function
of s
well to do that we just have to remind
ourselves that what we've drawn over
here what we've drawn over here is a
right triangle it's half it's the left
half of this equilateral triangle and we
know
what this bottom side of this right
triangle is this altitude splits this
side exactly into two so this right over
here has length s over two
so to figure out what h is we can just
use the pythagorean theorem we would
have h squared
plus s over two squared plus s over two
squared is going to be equal to the
hypotenuse squared is going to be equal
to s squared so you would get h squared
plus s squared over 4 is equal to s
squared subtract s squared over 4 from
both sides and you get h squared is
equal to
s squared minus s squared over 4.
now to do this i could call s squared i
could call this 4s squared over 4 just
to do just to be able to have a common
denominator and four s squared
minus s squared over four is going to be
equal to three
s squared over four so we get h squared
is equal to three s squared over four
now we can take the principal root of
both sides and we get h is equal to the
square root of three times s
over two
so now we can just substitute back right
over here and we get our area
our area is equal to one half
s times h well h is this business so
it's s times this so it's one half times
s
times the square root of three s
over two which is going to be equal to s
times s is s squared it's going to be
square root of 3
s squared over 2 times 2 over 4. so this
is the area of an equilateral triangle
as the function of the length of its
sides so what's the area of this
business going to be so the area of our
little equilateral triangle let me write
combined area let me do that in a
neutral color
so let me do that in y white so the
combined area
i'll write it a
sub c
is going to be equal to the area of my
triangle the area of my triangle a sub t
plus the area plus the area of my square
well the area of my triangle we know
what it's going to be it's going to be
square root of 3 times the length of a
side squared divided by four so it's
going to be square root of three
let me do that in that same yellow color
it's going to be
make sure i switch colors
it's going to be square root of three
over four times the side squared times x
over three
x over three
x
over three squared all i did is the
length of a side is x over three we
already know what the area is it's
square root of 3 over 4 times the length
of a side squared
and then the length of and then the area
of this square right over here the area
of the square is just going to be 100
minus x
over 4
over 4 squared so our area our combined
area and maybe i could write like this
our combined area as a function of where
we make the cut is all of this business
right over here and this is what we need
to minimize so we need to minimize
minimize
that right over there and i will do that
in the next video